hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute ein
richtig leckeres rezept nämlich
hefegebäck wir machen nougat knoten mit
zimt und das passt perfekt in die
bevorstehende jahreszeit denn herbst und
winter kommt man kann sich verhindern
ich habe ich auch schon ein bisschen
dicker angezogen und ich hab das rezept
heute aus dem neuen edeka backbuch das
zeige ich euch jetzt das gibt's ab
oktober im handel und zwar entweder bei
edeka markt kauft im buchhandel oder
auch gerne über den link den ich euch
unten in die infobox setzte das buch
wirklich toll denn es ist wirklich nicht
nur für profis sondern auch für
einsteiger also für jeden was dabei
und es um fast 200 seiten mit über 100
rezepten also da hat man wirklich was
von
und das beste ist ich darf am ende des
videos noch ein paar exemplare verlosen
also bleibt auf jeden fall bis zum
schluss dran und ich zeige euch jetzt
aber zuallererst die zutaten für unsere
leckeren nougat knoten
wir benötigen mail in einer ausreichend
großen schüssel außerdem geschmolzene
butter frische hefe lauwarme milch eine
prise salz und braunen zucker 1 eigelb
schnittfeste nuss nougat masse weiche
butter
außerdem sind und etwas puderzucker und
wir beginnen jetzt mit unserem hefeteig
dafür nehme ich mir jetzt einfach die
frische hefe zerbröselt sie in eine
schüssel geben da etwas von der milch
rein gratzl 100 milliliter und außerdem
noch ein teelöffel von den braunen
zucker der die nämlich als nährstoff für
die hefe
[Musik]
und dass milch hefe gemisch wird jetzt
richtig gut miteinander verrührt bis
sich alles gut aufgelöst hat die milch
sollte ungefähr eine temperatur von 32
grad haben so arbeitet die hefe nämlich
am besten dasteht übrigens auch im buch
drinne genauso wie weitere gute tipps
für grundzutaten zu und tage und für
backzutaten generell jetzt nehme ich mir
meine schüssel mit dem mehl und gibt da
schon mal das salz mit hinein und dann
wird das auch noch mal ganz gut
miteinander verrührt und das salz rundet
noch mal richtig den geschmack ab einem
süßem hefeteig und ich bilde jetzt in
der mitte der schüssel eine mulde gibt
dann unser hefe gemisch reinbeker das ab
und lasst sie das dann zehn minuten lang
arbeiten
[Musik]
nach zehn minuten sieht man deutlich
dass die hefe gearbeitet hat und da
gehen wir jetzt flüssige butter hinzu
die sollte nicht zu heiß sein
außerdem die lauwarme milch und das
eigelb und das eiweiß könnt ihr auch
weiter verwehrt nicht machen wie zum
beispiel spieler noch lecker rein und
gibt dass da noch mit rein
so und jetzt gebe ich noch 60 gramm des
braunen zucker sind so den rest
benötigen wir später und dann wird das
alles schön geknetet entweder mit den
händen oder ihr nehmt euer handrührgerät
mit dem knethaken
[Musik]
und ich mache das immer gerne so war
hilfe zeigen dass ich die letzten zwei
drei minuten mit den händen kneten
es hat dann einfach ein besseres gefühl
dafür ihr könnt mir gerne in die
kommentare schreiben wir das bei euch
ist das scheiden sich ja auch die
geister benutzt ihr über die
küchenmaschine das andere gerät oder
eure hände
[Musik]
nach wenigen minuten ist unser hefeteig
fertig jetzt gebe ich den nur noch in
meine schlüssel zurück gebe aber auf den
boden und auf den hefeteig noch etwas
mehr damit er auch nicht an klebt dann
gebe ich einen küchentuch oben drauf und
lass dir das eine stunde gehen bis sich
der teig verdoppelt hat und wir nutzen
jetzt aber die zwischenzeit während
unser hefeteig geht und bereiten die
nougat masse zu denn die müssen wir
vorbereitet
seine stücke schneiden etwas kleiner als
ein zentimeter also ungefähr 8 mm große
stücke und habt ihr mal lukas masse
probiert ich könnte ja so vernaschen
aber nein die muss später in unseren
hefeteig
[Musik]
und jetzt nehmen wir uns die nogat
stücke geben die auf einen teller und
dann werden nämlich eingefroren im
tiefkühlfach damit sie einfach fester
werden und wie sie später richtig schön
auf dem hefeteig verteilen können so in
die nubert stücke sind ausgehärtet und
unser teig ist wunderbar aufgegangen
schaut mal wie schön das aussieht und
jetzt nehmen wir ihn aus der schüssel
kneten die noch einmal ganz kurz durch
für ein paar sekunden und dann werde ich
ihnen auf der bemehlten arbeitsfläche
ausrollen und zwar quadratisch 40 x 40
cm
den teig habe ich jetzt ausgeräumt wie
gesagt auf 40 x 40 cm
ihr müsst nicht so genau sein also ein
paar zentimeter unterschied sind auch
nicht schimpft jetzt gebe ich die weiche
butter drauf butter ist ein wunderbarer
geschmacksträger und das verteilt er
jetzt einfach auf die oberfläche ist
deix
[Musik]
so die butter ist jetzt bis zum rand
bestrichen worden und jetzt gehen wir
unseren lukas darüber einfach so dass
überall was reinkommt
[Musik]
so und damit euer lukas richtig schön im
teig haften webb nimmt ihr euch jetzt
eure teigrolle und geht dann nochmal
ganz leicht drüber
und jetzt kommt mein lieblingsteil wir
geben jetzt zimt zum übrig gebliebenen
braunen zucker und das wird später so
lecker schmecken weil der zins sowieso
total lecker nach dem backen und der
zuckerwert karamellisieren ich liebe das
[Musik]
sobald ihr das dann verteilt habt werden
wir das ganze einmal umklappen und dann
werden wir uns zwölf strenge daraus
schneiden
so unsere zwölf strenge werden wir jetzt
zu knoten weiterverarbeiten da zeige ich
euch wie einfach das geht indem durch
ganz einfach ein strang
das wirbelt das in entgegengesetzte
richtungen und dann einfach zu einem
knoten zusammenfalten und so fertig und
so wie bis jetzt auch mal mit backpapier
ausgelegtes backblech
[Musik]
und ich lege die nogat knoten jetzt
gerne mit etwas abstand aufs blech da
sie ja noch ein bisschen größer
werdenden backofen und dann packe ich
sie auch zweimal das heißt auf zwei
backbleche ich gebe es jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen 180 grad ober und
unterhitze und backen sie dann 20
minuten bis sie schön goldbraun sind und
nach dem backen lasse ich sie nur so 23
minuten lang ausdampfen gibt da richtig
schön puderzucker oben drauf und dann
genieße ich das zu einer schönen tasse
latte macchiato ich habe es gelernt es
heißt nicht latte macchiato gab es all
die jahre falsche gesagt auf jeden fall
freue ich mich wenn ihr das rezept nach
macht ich schreibe euch die genauen
mengenangaben natürlich immer unten in
die infobox aber ich lasse euch noch
nicht gehen kleine moment noch wenn wir
dürfen drei backbücher verlosen ist das
nicht cool und ihr könnt total einfach
mitmachen die teilnahmebedingungen
schreibe ich euch unten in der infobox
das gewinnspiel geht sieben tage lang
und ihr werdet von mir benachrichtigt
das einzige was ihr tun müsst schreibt
mir unten in die kommentare was ist ihr
im herbst bzw im winter am liebsten ob
herzhaft oder süß schreibt einfach ich
freue mich auf euer zahlreiches
teilnehmen und sagt bis zum nächsten mal
auf die skizzen tschüss
[Musik]